all right
we are live could not possibly be more
to talk about I'm gonna talk about the
indictment I'll talk about the guilty
plea that some of you may not actually
have heard of involving George
papadopolis I will tell you about the
total and complete shutdown of the David
Pakman show zammis on affiliate link
which is bad it's really really not good
and I will tell you about that a little
bit later other piece of news there is
also now patreon is now fully integrated
with our on screen graphics for
contributions up here and the donations
that appear somewhere around here I
guess and you will see that as we see
contributions come in at patreon.com
slash david pakman show they show up as
pledged so I ran a bunch of tests before
we started those are the ones you're
seeing now and they show pledged as
opposed to just a dollar amount so
that's exciting and in the wake of the
total and complete shutdown of our
Amazon affiliate link that will be very
very useful and hopefully we'll bring in
some new patreon contributors so before
we get started number one if this is
your first live stream we are really
live unless we're not these are archived
then you can watch them at your leisure
afterwards so if it's not live it's
because you are watching a recorded live
stream but normally they're live and
because they're live you can and
actually this is I have a new version of
this graphic that I didn't bring in you
can ask questions and send comments not
only through super chat but also through
stream lab so you can use super chat
which is the dollar sign at the bottom
of the chat window
Jakub ball is on the ball he already
sent in a contribution a question before
we even started and I'll get to that one
momentarily you can also use stream labs
comm slash the david pakman show the
link is in the description that
circumvents the 30% fee that youtube
takes from super chat so we end up with
more of that money and new members and
patrons will get live thank-yous and
shout outs during the stream as I
mentioned patrons will also get
on-screen recognition
we now have integrated patreon with that
with with stream labs which runs those
graphics that's a really good thing
and please don't troll obvious trolling
will get you banned a lot of people are
banned shockingly I mean not a lot in
the context of our four hundred and two
thousand plus subscribers at this point
but a stunningly high number of people
get themselves banned by just coming in
and repeating the word [ __ ] a million
times or calling me a Jew bastard stuff
like that but subtle trolling probably
won't get you banned because the
moderators won't notice so the big news
today major news now remember I've been
dealing with the trolls saying David
you're a [ __ ] there will never be
charges this investigation is going
nowhere nothing is going to happen ever
and of course today we had former Trump
campaign manager and campaign chairman
Paul Manafort indicted on 12 counts 12
counts as well as Rick gates his
business partner and the big news is not
the content of the charges themselves it
was obvious when news broke of the
specific charges this morning we all
knew exactly what the reaction from
Krampus was going to be the reaction was
going to be none of this stuff has
anything to do with Trump or the
campaign and it all took place before
the campaign neither of those is true
number one a bunch of the indictments
have to do with activities that took
place during the campaign so it's just
flat-out not true to say that the timing
of what Paul Manta Ford is accused of
has nothing to do with the Trump
campaign but the big picture that people
are missing is that the mere fact that
there are charges against Paul Manafort
is the connection and you are not going
to see this certainly not from Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and will talk about her
stunning absolutely stunning press
briefing today you are not going to hear
this from any committed Trumpets man
affort was hired by Trump and he is the
link between Trump and Russia the idea
that the charges don't link Trump to any
of this man afford is the link so that's
number one
now beyond that George Papa
Poulos has pled guilty to lying to the
FBI in connection with the Trump Russia
investigation why did we learn about
that today it happened at the beginning
of the month that's interesting and it
might have been a strategic decision a
strategic decision by robert muller to
combine the release of that information
that george papadapolis pled guilty with
the news today that these indictments
have come forward and the reason for
that would be a signal potentially to
future people who are going to be
interviewed by the FBI by robert
Muller's team that if you lie to us
about this you are going to be charged
and we already have guilty pleas we
already have a guilty plea in the Trump
Russia investigation you're not going to
hear that said in these terms on Fox
News you're not going to hear it from
Sean Hannity check out his tweets by the
way check out what i retweeted from sean
hannity today at des Pakman on twitter
so we we have a guilty plea already the
idea
we often hear we've only now seen
charges the goal posts have been moved
so far that they're in the parking lot
of the stadium at this point we've only
seen charges we've not seen any guilty
pleas because Manafort pleaded not
guilty and gates pled not guilty
well no George papadopolis already pled
guilty on October 3rd or 5th or
something like that so do not fall for
what the right is telling you for what
the ideologically committed trumpets are
telling you now let's talk about legal
strategy why go with these indictments
now if these aren't the ones that most
directly linked Trump to collusion okay
very good question the answer we don't
know the answer but the answer may well
be in such a wide-ranging investigation
you start with your strongest cases and
you start with the people who are more
likely to flip and cooperate and let you
work up maybe up to and including in the
Oval Office okay and it is very widely
accepted legal strategy you don't start
with the most difficult cases to prove
with the highest possible people mana
fort clearly it seems that they've got
him dead to rights twelve counts here we
know they've been investigating mana for
for a long time robert muller brought in
specialists in money laundering and
financial crimes so it makes sense that
you go and charge mana fort first you
now create a possibility of mana fort or
others who have not yet been indicted
but are not at the highest levels of
this to say hey you know what this is
real this is my opportunity to talk to
the FBI implicate the higher-ups and get
myself out and i gave this example on
the broadcast program today Sammy the
bull Gravano admitted to killing almost
two dozen people ok mob connected guy
mobster he got sentenced to something
like five years most people don't get
sentenced to just five years when they
admit to multiple killings okay and the
reason for that there's a number of
reasons but a primary reason for that is
that he flipped and he allowed the FBI
and investigators to go after bigger
higher ups right so this is what you
have to understand about the strategy
about what's going on here and you know
the the talking points are totally
predictable this doesn't implicate Trump
okay well look at Watergate look at when
you had the first charges in Watergate
and look at the fact that it took almost
almost there just over I think it's just
under two years until you had the
resignation of Richard Nixon so prepare
yourselves Sarah huh we're gonna be
doing a full breakdown 17 or 20 minute
press briefing today from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders who I believe along with Jared
Kushner
and Sebastian Gorka are the most vile
and disgusting associates of the Trump
administration current or former I think
she is right up there and every time I
say it people say you're fat shaming and
it has absolutely nothing whatsoever to
do with Sarah Huckabee Sanders physical
appearance I find her demeanor and her
sort of audacity to lie in this
aggressive way Sean Spicer at least
seemed kind of betta when he would tell
his lies Sarah Huckabee Sanders tells
the lies with such audacity and such
boldness that it is even more vile I
believe than the lies that we heard day
after day after day from Sean Spicer so
we are going to be covering all of that
and it is it is stunning that this is
what we're dealing with and that this is
what's going on and remember you had
endless endless endless and endless
apologist for the Trump administration
saying we're never going to see a
serious investigation well we had a
serious investigation we're never going
to see anything in the Trump dossier
confirmed more and more of the Trump
dossier has been confirmed we're never
going to see charges we're never going
to see charges
we have charges at the highest level at
this time and this is going to be it is
you know maybe maybe an inappropriate
term because of the revelations about
Kevin Spacey which we talked about on
today's bonus show but this is a house
of cards and this is merely the
beginning Sarah Huckabee Sanders today
is trying to insist that this is going
to be wrapping up soon Moeller is going
to be wrapping up soon asks for evidence
as to why this is going to be wrapping
up soon
Sarah Huckabee Sanders could present no
evidence and I believe that this is not
going to be wrapping up anytime soon
let's jump into some of the super chat
comments as well as some of the stream
labs contributions because there are
many of them a lot of people wanting to
get involved in the discussion here
let's start with Jacob ball five bucks
do you think Trump would ever resign
would he force a vote for impeachment if
it came down to it would Republicans
actually vote for impeachment
I believe Trump would resign if he was
convinced he was about to be impeached I
do not believe that he would force the
impeachment vote if he really believed
he was about to be impeached and I think
it's going to be a tough sell for
Republicans to vote for impeachment of
Donald Trump legit British has sent one
a one British pound
super chat no question or comment thank
you very much Jay HWH Goodell has sent a
five euro super chat you sounded
positively giddy on today's show at the
prompt prospect of Trump's elite
enablers
have not used have not seen you this
happy for a while you misread by my
emotional state I it's not about being
happy it's about the possibility that
justice will be served and I don't know
that it will be but this is a beginning
this is just the start and and to be
quite honest I'm sad it's actually sad
and anger angering that this is where we
are that we have this going on right now
with our government rather than anything
that is going to be good for the middle
class or any of the groups Trump
promised to help other than the really
rich who will benefit from his tax
proposal if it goes through really a Z
no kidding has sent a $2 super chat
saying keep it up thank you I will Quan
Garcia has sent a $5 super chat were you
a fan of Eric the actor from Howard
Stern Show absolutely big big fan of
Eric the actor and it was it was a sad
day when he passed away and one of the
providers it's just some of the best
absolute best comedy of the Howard Stern
Show over the decades so big big fan of
Eric the actor no doubt about it
Olivia van gada has sent a $10 super
chat it's a negative one David has less
credibility than mainstream media
secular talking even The Young Turks
because he didn't even have the balls to
cover the Clinton dossier uranium
scandal eat a bite of crow you sad
excuse for a news journalist Olivia I
really appreciate that $10 contribution
to our program thank you Juan Garcia has
sent a $2 super chat the politically
correct version of f marry kill romantic
marry reject reject Sarah Palin Tommy
Lauren Ivanka I guess Ivanka Trump I
would probably I would probably reject
Palin marry Ivanka and be romantic with
with Tommy Lauren that's uh that's my
instinct and then Hwang Garcia coming up
with another $2 super Chad who's better
Leo Messi or Ronaldo Leo Messi 100% I
mean just absolutely not a question not
a question at all god of path has sent a
$5 Super chat how can one counter the
already happening Trump is pivot to
Hillary Podesta ukraine-russia link
I did it would happen the way to counter
it is to proceed please proceed as
President Obama once said to Willard
mittens Romney stick to the facts and
stick with the double standards
standards and stick with the goalposts
moving right there was never anything to
see and there would be no special
prosecutor what one was appointed there
would never be anything in the Trump
dossier proven to be true
endless elements of the Trump Russia
dossier have now been proven to be true
we would never see charges well we've
now got charges so remind the committed
trumpets that they have absolutely no
credibility at this point zero
credibility on any of these issues
because they've been wrong all along and
they cannot be trusted and Sarah
Huckabee son Sanders cannot be trusted
and it is there's no other way to say
why would we listen to any of you if
Robert Muller comes out and talks to us
about Hillary and uranium then we'll
think about it but in the meantime
there's no point whatsoever in even
talking about that I have some sad news
the I was just notified minutes before
going live with you here that the David
Pakman show Amazon affiliate link has
been kiboshed it has been totally shut
down there have been a number of
programs YouTube channels and other
shows that used the Amazon affiliate
link to fundraise that have lost it and
we are the next and this represented
about 10% of our of our yearly revenue
it became a bigger and bigger part of
our revenue over time and it's gone and
this is a bummer this is a bummer
because we started the year really
really strongly and then we had YouTube
ad pocalypse YouTube D monetization
which crushed absolutely crushed our
revenue and I've shown you that revenue
curve before and we started to build
some of that back up through patreon and
it then
imploded once again and it is such a
disappointment now to have lost that
amount of revenue particularly because
particularly because we were only just
starting to recover from the crushing
impact of YouTube ad pocalypse and if
you don't remember ad pocalypse or just
have forgotten about it ad pocalypse
happened when the Wall Street Journal
and a couple of other media outlets
pointed out that hey occasionally some
advertisements will sneak through the
YouTube ad algorithm which is supposed
to prevent ads from showing up on racist
or hateful content and there's a really
really good ad that is on the a really
really good article about this in Wired
magazine which is by davey alba and it
basically outlines every aspect of how
this has affected the david pakman show
there is another article that you can
check out which is in The New York Times
and it is has also talked about how this
has absolutely and utterly crushed the
david pakman show and I've talked about
it before and we were just starting to
make headway and all of a sudden today
we get crushed and lose our affiliate
link so first and foremost right number
one most important thing thanks to
everybody who has used our Amazon
affiliate link over the years but it is
no more and that is why it is going to
be even more important over the coming
months that we replace that revenue as
if this is not as if this is a problem
that I wanted to deal with but I do
invite you to make a contribution at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
have an animation that will appear on
screen if you make any contribution via
patreon at all nobody has done that yet
but you will see your name appear up in
this list as soon as you do it and you
will also see an animation down here
similar to the super chat animation but
a different Super Mario animation so
it's a bummer and it's just we've really
been taking it on the chin this year and
we're working as hard as we can
to produce more and more content and
then sadly we're dealing with one one
revenue hit after another so I hope
people will consider particularly if you
ever use that Amazon link maybe replace
that replace that with a dollar or two
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and you'll you'll be doing a lot and
it's bad it's really really bad out
there let me get back here to some of
the super chat questions that are going
on Shaun Hanson has sent the ten dollar
super chat I've seen a lot of talk about
Trump getting Moeller fired or dismissed
do you think this is even a remote
possibility no I think at this point
Donald Trump knows that Moeller is too
far in it would be an absolute and utter
scandal it would be political suicide at
this point to fire Robert Muller and we
did a segment on the show today about
Fox News's judge Jeanine Pirro who's
absolutely disgusting and she said as a
result of the indictment news it's time
to shut down the investigation and to
lock up Hillary Clinton and how someone
could come away with that conclusion
from what we learned over the last 48
hours I don't know
game fire 74 has sent a $6 81 cents
super chatez I am a CPA and I want to
thank you for your Republican 401k story
if anything you understated the damage
to the middle class the $18,000 401k
contribution cap down to $2,400 is a
disaster yeah if you're not aware of
that the some versions of the Republican
tax plan would lower the yearly
contribution limit for individual
taxpayers to 401ks from $18,000 to
$2,400 those contributions are tax
deductible the rich don't need 401ks
they have much more sophisticated
vehicles that they can use self funded
pension plans and many other methods so
this is hugely regressive it is a
destructive blow to the middle class if
it happens and we outlined that in some
detail today on the David Pakman show
Brody Andrew Mulligan sent a $2 super
chat
and will you play the drums or your
practice pad yeah I've got my drums and
prior or rather my practice pad back
here and you know what I'll tell you if
we get to 1984 patreon contributors
tonight I will play a little something
for you on my practice pad we're at 1966
my year of birth was 1984 that's only 18
patreon contributions it's about 3% of
the people on the stream right now if we
get to 1984 patreon contributions I will
drag the practice pad over and play a
little double stroke roll for you and
you will also see a nice animation pop
up because now we have patreon fully
integrated with our on-screen graphics
so something to think about if that's
interesting consider making a patreon
contribution Quan Garcia has sent a
five-dollar super chat as a fan of your
show I have to say that I am stunned
that less than 1% of subscribers donate
come on people help this man out he's
the best progressive on YouTube thanks
Juan you've been here for a while and
you've been contributing generously and
I appreciate that that's true we
estimate that under 1% of our total
audience contributes anything
financially and that's why we only need
to make a very small increase if we can
get to 2 or 3 percent of our audience
making any kind of a contribution even
what I consider sort of the smallest
possible contribution which is $1 a
month through patreon if we can just get
to 2 or 3 percent the program would be
so well funded that we could grow and
grow and do more things and I'd never
have to talk to you about fundraising
because honestly I don't want to I'd
rather talk about other things but the
fundraising is a necessity
Oscar edge has sent a 100 Swedish kronor
super chat how much is that 100 SEK two
US dollars it's about six let's sing no
1196 thank you very generous
contribution appreciate that Pamela
Brewer has sent a $2 super chat with no
question or comment thank you gr has
sent a $10 super chat stick a fork in
metaphor it boy bout to be eating spam
with a spork with Huck
boo in Trump colored jumpsuit sell the
Trump stock and watch Trump break in
rocks and slip on shoes and ankle socks
very nice rhyming gr appreciate that
Pamela Brewer with another $2 super chat
and Oscar edge with a 20 Swedish kronor
contribution thank you very much I
appreciate that let me go over to stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show
that's the other place you can
contribute and circumvent youtube's $30
super check cut sean has sent the $7
stream lapse contribution love the show
keep up the good work I'm gonna be
seeing Richard Dawkins and sam Harris
and Vancouver in a few days and I'm
wondering what I should ask them in the
Q&A ask them why they've never been on
the David Pakman show I've invited both
both of them Richard Dawkins staff wrote
back and said he'd be interested and
then they never came back
with some possible dates try as we might
to secure a date Sam Harris has never
responded to interview requests that is
the question that you should ask why
haven't you not been on the David Pakman
show and that will that would be a
really good thing make that happen let's
move let's do it back over to super chat
we have a five US dollar super chat from
Belger wrath 1966 which is more
significant for getting us closer to a
trump impeachment Papadopoulos is guilty
plea or mana Ford's
indictment I'm not thinking about in
those terms I I do believe that the
Papadopoulos guilty plea is more
definitively damning in terms of the
activities of the Trump campaign because
it's very easy although I think it's
it's a specious argument it is easy to
bamboozle people by saying Manafort
and gates have been charged accusations
and indictments are not proof of
anything so far no wrongdoing has been
actually legally indicated but a guilty
plea from Papadopoulos is closer to
irrefutable wrongdoing although
you will have some people who will say
hey listen he was being railroaded he
had to plead guilty because he would
have been railroaded by a total kangaroo
court had he fought the charges or
something like that I don't know but I
do think that the Papadopoulos guilty
plea is in the in the immediate it's
very powerful is I guess what I'm
getting at levan Gann Avanti Ghana body
has sent a twenty dollar super chat with
just a smiley face wearing sunglasses no
question or comment thank you very much
Susan Paine has sent a five-dollar super
chat thank you very much
Jacob ball has sent the five dollar
super chat is having only 1% of your
audience supporting you typical on
YouTube how does that compare to the
Young Turks or secular talk I don't know
I don't know Jacob but it is depressing
it is absolutely depressing
Brody Andrew Mulligan $3.00 super chat
when will Pat be back on the regular
show Pat was on the regular show Friday
we heard from Pat during audience
questions I think he chimed in during
phone calls as well
Pat's role is constantly evolving but
Pat has been still regularly on the
regular show he had some great
contributions today on the bonus show so
no particular plan everybody's roles are
constantly evolving on the show and Pat
is Pat's there Pat's right in there
game fire 74 cent a $2.00 super Chet
thanks for no live stream during Rachel
Maddow's hour yeah I had to do an
earlier live stream today because I
actually have very very exciting I have
a condo board meeting I'm on the board
of my condo association and we have a
board meeting going on later today so
that that's that affected the schedule
for today's live stream so thanks thanks
very much okay let me do a couple
thank-yous here because we do have thank
yous happening of course membership
continues to be the number one funding
source for the David Pakman show and I
want to welcome Andrew Church who has
just made a new membership at david
pakman.com
komm slash membership and it is a very
very big thing I appreciate it
I also want to thank and I don't know
why this didn't work they're supposed to
be we see here I don't see we just had a
new patreon pledge from min Cheol Zhang
who pledged two dollars a month I hope I
didn't butcher your name there I assumed
I did and the names are supposed to show
up up here but I'm not seeing it that's
really weird I don't know why that's
happening let me see if I can check out
if I go over here to my stream Labs
interface let me do a test pledge here
John pledged $58 via patreon and then it
shows up here yeah I don't I don't know
why it's not working
I don't know why why that wouldn't I'm
gonna have to check that out why would
that not be working integrations I don't
know what the setting is but patreon is
engaged right now so I don't know why I
don't know why it wouldn't work I
apologize for that but in any case thank
you very very much
thanks to everybody who has been
contributing through patreon and through
all of those other platforms but I will
try to get that fixed in advance for the
next livestream because I want that I
want that to show up and also thanks to
Richard a Gil V who has upped his pledge
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
from one dollar a month to five dollars
a month
very very exciting and I really do
appreciate that every patreon
contributor makes a difference Mario
Sonique has made a four euro super chat
keep going from a Croat in Vienna
Austria thank you very much and Danny
Raman has sent a $2.00 super chat using
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window thanks very much really
appreciate that and we've got a lot of
big things coming up for the David
Pakman show we're gonna be digging in
tomorrow if you thought that the news
ended with the indictment of Paul
Manafort and gates and the release of
the the we learned about the guilty plea
from George
a trump associate involved in foreign
policy advising guilty plea for lying to
the FBI if you thought that was the end
of it
just you wait because tomorrow's program
is going to be huge we have seen Donald
Trump's approval rating crash all the
way down to a new Gallup rolling
approval rating average of 33 percent
his previous low was 34 percent in the
Gallup poll he has now hit 33 percent
and that's data from before from before
the news of this this indictment broke I
don't necessarily expect the indictment
to push Trump's approval rating down but
I certainly don't believe it's going to
help so very very interesting that yet
again Donald Trump has hit another new
low in terms of approval rating we were
going to I've been watching I've been
watching today's Sarah Huckabee Sanders
press briefing like the Zapruder film
I'm slowing it down and and checking
every vile sneer that she puts on her
face but it is stunning we are going to
have how many clips did I flag from this
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 different clips from
Sarah Huckabee Sanders press briefing
today unhinged denials and misdirections
when it comes to the indictment of Paul
Manafort I believe that today's day
today for Donald Trump was the worst day
of his presidency so far and as one of
our reddit users pointed out Paul
Manafort and gates indicted we learned
George papadopolis pled guilty to lying
to the FBI as part of the Trump Russia
investigation record low Trump approval
rating and Trump's transgender military
ban has been halted by a court today was
the worst day for Donald Trump's
administration since the beginning since
the beginning of this what do we have so
far by nine months and ten days of his
administration we'll be talking about
that on tomorrow's program we'll be
talking about the court blocking Trump's
military transgender ban we've learned
that
more than half of trumps nominees for
different positions have ties conflicts
of interest within the industries
they're supposed to be regulating we
learned that the cross-check system
being used to remove voters from the
voter rolls in Indiana that the system
is 99% inaccurate 99% of those removed
by the system are not our valid voters
who shouldn't be removed from the system
so tomorrow is one of the biggest shows
in a long time in a long time on the
david packard show let's go over to some
of the stream labs comment stream labs
comm slash the david pakman show min
sent a dollar comment I've been
bamboozled no name on screen
I apologize men I thought I had set it
up so that when someone makes a patreon
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show that there is supposed to be an
animation that comes up on screen and
when I tested it which I'll do again
just to show you that I'm not I was not
deliberately bamboozling you let me see
if I can do this is it working
it's not even working I'm not even able
to let me see if I can do this go over
to pledges here and do a test pledge
what's supposed to happen and I thought
that this was this was a really cool
integration what's supposed to happen
when someone makes a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show is
that your name comes up up here along
with all these other people who are
making contributions through stream labs
and through super chat and for whatever
reason it didn't happen it didn't happen
when when min made that contribution
let's do a test pledge and there it is
see the test works it shows up as
pledged over here and then this cool
animation comes up down here I don't
know why it didn't work and I'm gonna
reach out to stream labs in advance of
the next one but believe me I appreciate
it just as much men I appreciate it just
as much despite the fact that the
didn't play and Joe has sent a two
dollar and sixty four cent patreon
contribution under super chat we've got
a couple other comments here under super
chat let's see where I left off blue
world 13 sent to do two dollar super
chat thank you very much Jacob ball sent
the two dollar super chat you should do
early live streams more often I'd love
to be doing more live streams in general
Jacob but it's tough it's tough with my
schedule actual justice warrior sent a
five dollar super chat how do you feel
about the JFK files revealing that they
sent Hitler and many top Nazis to
Argentina which has been a safe and
closed Jewish community
Hitler was sent to Argentina I did not
hear that I was under the impression
Hitler died FBI files prove Adolf Hitler
escaped to Argentina Snopes has an
article about this and they have said
that that's false yeah they say that
that's absolutely not true yeah I'll
have to read that but it appears as
though that is fake news
Rammstein Rammstein rules $0.16 the
twenty Canadian dollar super jet hey
Dave have been a subscriber for a little
while now love what you do what do you
see the progression of politics in the
US and your future what would you like
to see all the best and all the support
from Vancouver British Columbia I would
like to see I mean I think the two big
issues are number one money in politics
and number two we need Instant Runoff
voting the real path forward for a
restructuring of American politics in a
way that I think would be good would
would require we got to get rid of
citizens united we have to really change
how politics is paid for and then we
need to put in place Instant Runoff
voting
I think Instant Runoff voting would
enable the rise of third parties because
people could say okay I'd like to vote
for this third party candidate but I
don't want to inadvertently help the
person I really disagree with win so
with Instant Runoff voting you could say
my number one choice is whatever third
party candidate if after one tally they
are not viable as the winner
then shift my vote over to this other
person and it's it's a really good
system for preventing people who would
like to support a third party candidate
from inadvertently helping the real
nutjob for lack of a better term to win
so that's what I would like to see
laura-leigh sent the two British pound
super chat any UK visit plans love the
show from London I was in the UK under a
year ago at the end I think it was the
last close to the end of 2016 I spent a
week in London and I enjoyed the city I
did not so much enjoy the cuisine
British cuisine did not strike me as
great but I had some of the best Indian
food of my life in London which was
tremendous JH WH Goodall has sent the 10
euro super chat your interviews were
really interesting lately but there was
always a lot of agreement where there
not many controversial figures on or
being from Austria do I just not know
them I don't know I mean we're getting
more knows actually from people who
where it would be an adversarial
interview interestingly enough we're
getting more and more knows and I think
it might be because they're researching
interviews that we've done with
adversarial people and maybe some of
them don't want to be on but I've got
some stuff up my sleeve that I'm working
on says II Canales has sent the $25
super Chad the high watermark for today
$25 as the high watermark 2501 is the
challenge 2501 and over its stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show
gigantic has sent a $5 stream lapse
contribution hey which hey chat which
sounds cooler
can't crack the pack or leader of the
pack okay gigantic is asking all of you
fine folks that question which do you
like better for what I don't know can't
crack the pack or leader of the pack
okay well there you go people can judge
judge for themselves I do want to thank
Deborah Smith Deborah Smith has signed
up for a new membership no coupon code
level to membership Deborah Smith thank
you very very generous
and I really appreciate that Deborah
Smith signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership she paid full price but
you don't have to pay full price you can
use the coupon code
I voted seventeen as you can see here on
page two of the signup you input the
code
I voted seventeen and that will save you
forty percent who doesn't like forty
percent savings I think it's absolutely
fantastic and let's let's do this
patreon thing okay I apologize I thought
that I had it all set up so that you
would see your name pop up up here when
you make a patreon contribution but I'll
do you one better
any patreon contributions that come in
between now and the end of the stream
you won't just see your name pop up on
screen I will personally thank you and
talk about what a great person you are
and I mentioned earlier in the stream we
have just suffered another financial
hardship at the David Pakman show it's
like a comedy of errors except there's
nothing funny about it we had this thing
called an Amazon affiliate link for a
long time and people could use the link
and then they would buy stuff on Amazon
and we would get a little bit of money
and it's been shut down and other
youtubers and podcasters have talked
about the fact that their Amazon
affiliate links have been shut down for
being used inappropriately
because more than likely we're not
really doing what you're supposed to do
what you're supposed to do is like have
a website about tennis racquets and then
you recommend and review tennis rackets
and people who use your links to buy
tennis rackets you get a little bit of a
cut from that from Amazon we're just
basically upfront and we say if you're
going to shop on Amazon use our link and
we'll get a kickback and apparently that
is in violation of use of Amazon's Terms
& Conditions so a bunch of us have
started getting our Amazon links shut
down and it happened like a half-hour
ago
right before I went on the livestream so
it's a very small ask that I have which
is if you can afford it if you can
afford $1 a month
I'm not talking about a lot of money $1
a month right we're talking about three
three cents a day please make a pledge
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
it's not just charity because we produce
extra content for our patreon
contributors you get the bonus show at
the $5 level you get the bonus show in
the full show at the $10 level you can
also get those member benefits as a
member right at david pakman.com slash
membership and we've got some really
great stuff planned as you can see at
the bottom left of this screen it says
1966 out of 2000 when we reach 2000
patrons I'll do an entire broadcast show
from the studio with my hair like this
and that is the target that's what
happens at 2,000 patrons but if you
click the little right arrow next to
where it says goals view all you'll see
that we also have a goal of 2500 patrons
and when we hit 2500 patrons we will be
producing in fully fully edited and
really nicely done a format we are going
to take my 12 lectures from the college
class that I've been teaching at Boston
College and turn them into 75 minute
YouTube lectures with slides
examples videos the entire thing okay
and I think that that's going to be
something everybody will really like our
patreon contributors will get early
access to those lectures and they will
eventually be made available to
everybody on YouTube and we talk about
epistemology and critical thinking and
media literacy we do an analysis of
advertisements we do a media fallacy
logical fallacy and media bias
discussion it's really really great
stuff and we've committed to doing that
once we get to 2500 patrons so please
get those contributions in side Madera
or side modder I don't know how you
pronounce your name has just pledged two
dollars a month and that's a really
really great thing I appreciate that
please keep those contributions coming
and I promise I will thank every single
one of you who makes a patreon
contribution everybody deserves it I
appreciate the generosity and I
encourage you to make those
contributions and one other thank you -
Leslie Loudermilk who has made a $2
super chat pledge and I appreciate that
today on the broadcast show
I interviewed a former CIA operations
agent and Marc Sageman is his name and
we talked about the origins and
catalysts for terror and radicalization
and it was a very interesting interview
the full interview will be out on
YouTube later we have part one of that
interview on today's broadcast show part
two of the interview will be on
tomorrow's very very interesting
interview on Wednesday I'll be
interviewing Graham Allison Graham
Allison will be interviewed on Wednesday
and he's a professor at the Harvard
Kennedy School if you're not familiar
with Graham outs and I encourage you to
google his name Google Graham Allison
Harvard and his name will come up and
when he joins me we are going to be
talking about China as a superpower
Graham Allison makes the case that China
is already the world's superpower
we often have these discussions of well
the way things are headed China's going
to be the next the the world superpower
the world's superpower I guess is what I
mean and he says Graham Allison says
China's already the world's superpower
we'll be talking to him on Wednesday and
then Thursday by popular demand I will
be interviewing endocrinologist Robert
Lustig dr. Robert Lustig he is known for
talking about sugar and the dangers of
high sugar consumption for human health
and he has a new book called hacking the
American mind for years people have been
telling me David please interview please
interview dr. Robert Lustig and we've
gotten it booked and I'm going to be
interviewing him and I think it's gonna
be a fantastic fantastic interview so
that's what's upcoming on the program
ninh jax x has sent a $10 super chat
remember when I said Trump was a Russian
puppet how about that indictment now we
all know the White House will be all
like oh he just got us coffee sometimes
but seriously it's obvious now yeah we
replayed today the Sean Spicer clip
where Spicer said listen man afore
worked for the campaign for a couple
weeks and he had a minor role
that's gonna have to be the the line
Sara Huckabee Sanders today said that
the that George papadopolis who pled
guilty we learned earlier this month to
lying to rot two FBI investigators in
the Trump Russia in course of the Trump
Russia investigation he was some minor
player wasn't a big deal he didn't
really do anything that's gonna be the
line so you're absolutely right
$5 a super chat from Brian Rasmussen
what do you think is a larger influence
on a person's political affiliation
education level economic standing or
family affiliation family affiliation
sorry I just hit my desk here probably
was loud
I believe family affiliation much more
so than anything else is an indicator of
your likely politics however education
level and economic standing do influence
that but I think that if you have a
progressive family you are very likely
to be progressive there could be
economic factors or education factors
that might push you the other direction
right people go against the politics of
their parents all the time but I think
family affiliation statistically would
be the most highly correlated with
political beliefs game fire seventy for
two dollars super check are you getting
married how long y'all been together
been together a long time can't say
nothing to announce nothing to announce
about pending pending nuptials at this
time Jacob ball has sent the five-dollar
superjet Trump would never say oh he
just got his coffee it would be oh he
just got his cob feffy yeah good
correction tune in Jax X's comment its
Cobb feffy when it comes to Trump not
not not coffee couple other
contributions and questions over at
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show gigantic cent to $5 super chat
david i think ice not super chat stream
labs contribution david I think I speak
for everyone here when I actually love
it when you do influencer advertising
when you reviewed those shoes that would
cure you of your lack of height compared
to Pat and Louis chat look up vivid edge
media to see funny Pakman ads yeah we we
were more actively pursuing this for a
while
but I've laid off of it a little bit but
I did once review some ha basically
their lifts their shoes that inside of
them have sort of like a heel padding
and they gave me I think it was like two
and a half extra inches and two and a
half extra inches makes a big difference
you can you can talk to people about
that but every inch can make a major
difference in life that's for sure
what else here sick sick E Hasselblad
has set a second
let's see says e canal has sent the $25
super chat sir this is second place
23.94 sent stream Labs contribution
without that David Pakman show the world
would be a darker place donate to hope
you will stay on air I'm already a
member thank you so much and just for
people who don't know when people
contribute to the David Pakman show if
there's way more going on than just
YouTube clips a lot of people don't know
this and when I say a lot of people
don't know this I don't mean what Trump
means which is I didn't know this until
two minutes ago
I actually mean a lot of people don't
know this the David Pakman show is on
200 broadcasts radio and TV stations
those are non-commercial stations
community radio and community television
stations they can't afford to pay for
our show so we charge them nothing I see
it not only is a community service I see
it as a community duty that if I am
producing this show I need to provide it
to as many community stations as
possible to get alternative media
viewpoints out to people who might
otherwise be getting no political news
at all or just the sort of status quo
corporate media outlet outlines so your
donations of even $1 a month are funding
the distribution of our show to 200
radio and television stations around the
country as well as DirecTV and Dish
Network through free speech TV we pay
for all that stuff right we pay rent at
the studio we pay for staff we pay for
connectivity we pay for technology we
create different versions of the show so
that it will work with the file systems
of our different affiliates that is
heavily subsidized
when you go to patreon.com/scishow and
throw in a dollar that is heavily
subsidized by you going to david
pakman.com slash membership and signing
up for a three dollar and 60 cent
membership with the coupon code
I voted 17 and on that note I want to
say thank you to a Sylvia Meadows who
has just signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership i want to say thank you
to JD penny
who has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership I want to
thank Jack whiting who has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership every
single one of you is not only getting
the bonus show and the commercial free
full show and those member perks which
are really great for you
but you're also subsidizing the entire
production and distribution of our show
to these non-commercial radio stations
that couldn't afford to pay us even 25
bucks a month for the show and on that
note i also want to say thank you to
bethany myers bethany myers has made a
pledge of two dollars per month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
i really appreciate that as well and the
offer still stands if we can get to 1984
i was born in 1984 if we get to 1984
patrons by the end of the stream i will
pull out the practice drum pad that's
over here and i'll play a little double
stroke roll for you and do some room
rudiments and i have never done that
before on the david pakman show and i
think that you would enjoy that and also
thanks to junus nap hanky who has just
signed up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership okay a
couple other comments through super chat
gr has sent a $2 super check gigantic is
the coolest lauren thomas is too fine
lauren big shout out to lauren lauren is
double duty moderator on both our reddit
discussion forum which is rapidly
approaching 5,000 5,000 users and we now
have several moderators that are keeping
things under control there and lauren is
also a super chat moderator
during the livestream so shout out to
her from gr Quan Garcia
I sent the five dollar super chat if you
were president what would be your three
main priorities is legal marijuana on
the list I support legal marijuana and I
think that it is an absolute atrocity
that marijuana when we have legal
alcohol and cigarettes that we don't
have legal marijuana that doesn't make
sense
marijuana being scheduled the same way
as heroin doesn't make sense and the war
on drugs used to disproportionately
prosecute and incarcerate non-white
Americans under the guise of under the
guise of making everything better
through the war on drugs which of course
doesn't happen absolutely terrible but I
don't know that would be that those
would be my three priorities I think my
three priorities if I were president
which I could never be because I wasn't
born in the United States by the way
would be money in politics Instant
Runoff voting and health care for all I
think those would be my three immediate
priorities all pretty big things will
Blake 72 has sent a $25 super chat tying
today's top super chat contribution hey
David
you've mentioned dabbling in Bitcoin
aetherium and litecoin have you
considered adding your wallet addresses
to your video descriptions to accept
one-time tips thanks man I appreciate
what you and the team do here's the
question and I don't know the answer and
if one of you can answer it I will do
that I use coin base to make small
purchases of cryptocurrency just kind of
to learn about it and dabble in it it's
not something I have a lot of money to
contribute to if I am able to accept
Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin through
coinbase somebody please let me know how
and I will immediately particularly
since today we lost our Amazon affiliate
link and we've got to make up that money
somehow I will immediately add whatever
I need to add in order to be able to
receive Bitcoin litecoin and aetherium
contribution so if it can be done
through coin base where people make
contributions and the money goes in
directly please let me know and I will
make that happen by the end of the week
okay
and no doubt about it game fire 74 two
dollars super Chet I'm in favor of a
second remenant repeal a second
amendment repeal am I alone you're not
alone but I think it's complex and I
don't think that that is my I don't
think that that's the most pragmatic way
to go about fixing the gun safety issue
I'm trying to pick my words carefully
here
Sarah Dobson has sent a 250 pound super
chat my first Pakman live show a
favorite part of my day thank you glad
to have you
Wladimir house has sent a $2 super chat
hello from Costa Rica I would love to go
to Costa Rica I've got a friend who let
me pull up a map of Costa Rica to see if
I can describe exactly where this is
Vladimir maybe you can follow up and
tell us whether my friend is on to
something Costa Rica map my friend now
vacations in a part of Costa Rica that
is very very remote so you've got the
capital of Costa Rica son cassette over
on the Pacific Ocean and if people want
to look at a map of Costa Rica with me
by all means feel free you've got this
peninsula which appears to be called
Peninsula the Nicosia or as would be
pronounced outside of Argentina nicoia
and my friend has found some part of
that Peninsula which you have to fly
into the capital and then take this tiny
tiny plane like a 16 passenger prop
plane out - and then it's like an hour
ride from there that he says is very
unknown to most American tourists but
have start it started to become popular
for some European tourists and that it
is very very pristine and almost
untouched in some ways and that there
are great restaurants being developed
and that it's just a great place with
great beaches and it's not particularly
expensive it's just difficult to get to
so anyway I'm trying to it's not like
he's keeping it a secret for me I just
don't remember the name of it I'm very
interested in going to Costa Rica and
that
that's something that's on my on my
radar Bryan Rasmussen has sent the five
dollar super check why were your parents
in Argentina when you were born because
they were born there were they Nazi
hunters they were not know four of my
five I'm sorry
three of my four grandparents were born
in Argentina both of my parents were
born in Argentina and thus I was in born
in Argentina as well
Roger Anand has sent a 15-dollar super
chat if you could interview Donald Trump
would you of course I don't know that
many people with political talk shows
would turn down interviews with the
president of the country and what would
you ask we don't have time for that but
I think I would start with trying to get
Trump to admit that he regrets having
run for president in the first place
let's see min has sent a $5 stream
labs.com
slashed the David Pakman show
contribution I have a lot of family
living in Seoul and all of the talk of
escalation with the DPRK has gotten me
very afraid for the safety of my family
are there things we can do as
individuals to influence people like
Trump in policy decisions outside of
elections not when it comes to something
like North Korea Trump is so unhinged
that the answer is basically no it we're
gonna have to hope that his generals as
he says can prevent him from doing
insane stuff when it comes to North
Korea that's that's just sort of the
reality however let me give you one
positive note I have I have several
friends here in Boston who are South
Korean Korean family in South Korea and
they say that their families in South
Korea are not particularly worried and
now it could be because they're
desensitized to constant drama with the
DPRK but it could be because they
genuinely don't think it's going to
escalate and and hopefully they're right
gigantic has sent a $2 stream lapse
contribution should Luis join secular
talk I think it would benefit Kyle to
have something other than a heart rate
monitor in the background of his videos
will you give Luis a good reference I
can assure you that Luis is not looking
at this time to get back into a a sort
of producer sidekick
position and I can double assure you
that he has no interest in moving to the
area of new I don't know how much Kyle
says about where he's located but New
York period
I'll keep it there because I don't know
if Kyle says where he lives new members
to think I want to thank Sarah Dobson
for signing up a david pakman.com slash
membership thank you very much Sarah I
appreciate it
every single member is making a big
difference I announced at the top of the
stream it's like ever every day it seems
to get worse but I announced at the top
of the stream that we lost our Amazon
affiliate link today a lot of shows like
ours have sadly been getting they've
sadly been been getting their Amazon
affiliate links shut down and we lost
ours today and we've got to make up for
it I would love to make up for it
through patreon I would look to love to
make up for it through membership both
are options we started the evening at
1966 patrons were up to 1969 and I've
said if we get to 1984 patrons that's
the year I was born I would pull out the
old practice pad the drum practice pad
back here and play a couple rudiments
for you but it's not looking
particularly good it's not looking
particularly good right now
couple other super chats here I hate
apricots has sent a $2 super chat
Richard Spencer all right lives in
Whitefish Montana thank you very much if
anybody was wondering where Richard
Spencer lives now we know Jacob ball has
sent the $5 super chat Trump might
regret having run for president no one
could have known being president could
could president would be so hard you
have to assume at this point Trump
absolutely regrets running for president
HK has sent a ten British pound super
check I'm in the UK and my blueberries
come from Argentina that is all I have
to say yeah i don't know that i've
gotten argentinian blueberries before
I've had argentinian pears in the US and
there's a lot of soy is a big thing in
Argentina so I've had presumably I've
had Argentinians
I couldn't I couldn't say for sure but
blueberries there you go very very
exciting and on that note I've got a run
to my condo board meeting I'm on the
board of my condo association I was
elected I did not choose to run but I
was elected anyway and I am choosing to
serve an indefinite term a term of
indefinite duration on my condo board
and we've got a meeting in a little bit
so I'm gonna get to that thanks to
everybody who joined me make a patreon
contribution just a dollar just throw in
a dollar I know many of you can afford
it dollar a month I will thank you on
the next stream and that'll be soon
it'll be soon